solve 6 to the x power is equal to 45
and give x to the nearest hundredth so
we have 6 to the x power is equal to
is equal to 45. so to solve this i'm
going to take the logarithm of both
sides of this equation and there's
multiple
different bases i could do but i'm going
to take the log base 10 of both sides of
this equation and the reason i'm going
to is because to really solve this i'm
going to have to use my calculator and
my calculator has a log base 10 function
so let's do that so this is log
base 10
log base 10 of both sides if 6 to the x
is really equal to 45 then the power
that i have to raise 10 to to get to 6
to the x is the same power i have to get
raised 10 2 to get to 45. now right over
here we know from our logarithm
properties this thing right over here
if we have the logarithm of something to
the something power something to the x
power that's the same thing as x times
the logarithm
x times the logarithm of that something
which was the 6 right over there so you
can move this
out front that exponent and that's going
to be equal to
that's going to be equal to i want to
stay
the logarithm base 10 of 45
of 45 and now we can just solve for x we
can divide both sides of this equation
we can divide both sides of this
equation by the log
base 10 of 6 divide both sides with a
log
base 10 of 6. this cancels out and then
we are left with
x is equal to
x is equal to the log
base 10 of 45
over the log
base 10 of 6. and this is useful because
i can actually calculate this on my
calculator and there's one thing i want
to show you because well let's just
calculate the problem and then i'll show
you the thing that i want to show you
so to do this let's turn the calculator
on let me clear what i had from the last
problem so the log base 10 of 45 i can
literally just use the log button log of
45 that means base 10. if someone just
writes a log without the little
subscript 10 this means base 10. so
that's log base 10 of 45
divided by
log
log base 10 of 6.
and that gets us
that gets us
2.12 so we want to round to the nearest
hundredth the thousands place is less
than five so it's 2.12 so this is
this is approximately equal to
approximately equal to 2.12 which makes
sense because 6 squared is 36 45 is a
little larger than and then 36 6 to the
third power is much larger so you get
2.12 and you can verify it for yourself
raise 6 to the 2.12 power actually let
me do that with the calculator so let me
raise 6
to the
2.12 and obviously i rounded it so it
won't be exact but it should get pretty
close to 45.
yep got pretty close to 45. if i had if
i added some more precision i would have
gotten even more i would have even
gotten even closer six point
two point
one two let's try four five three eight
or four five
three eight
seven
7 and then let me round that one 9 so
let's see what happens here so now we're
getting much much much closer to 45 now
what i want to show you is by taking
both logarithm base 10 of both sides and
we did that because log base 10 is a
function on our calculator we
essentially we essentially kind of
reproved the change of base formula
because when you're trying to solve 6 to
the x
is equal to 45 one way you could do it
is
one way you could do it is you could
take the the log base 6 of both sides so
you could have taken log
base 6 of that side and log base 6 of
that side
and what is the power that i have to
raise 6 2 to get 2 6 to the x power well
i have to raise that to the x power so
this thing would simplify as just x one
way to think about it is you could take
this exponent using logarithm properties
put them put it out here
put it out here and then you say well
what power would have to raise 6 2 to
get to 6 well you have to raise it to
the first power so this part simplifies
to 1 you just have x times 1 is just x
so the left hand side regardless of how
you think about it simplifies to x the
right hand side becomes is equal to log
base 6 of 45 and this is once again it's
something that i can't do this in my
head but we know we by going the other
way by taking log base 10 we figured out
that this is the exact same thing as log
base 10 of 45
over log base 10 of 6.
so what we essentially showed is the
change of base formula using the
specific case of 6
6 and 45.